This lecture is about the topic mining
and analysis.
We are going to talk about using a term
as topic.
This is a slide that you have seen in
the earlier lecture where we defined
the task of top mining and analysis.
We also raised the question how do we
exactly define the topic theta?
So in this lecture we are going to offer
one way to define it, and that's our
initial idea.
Our idea here is to define a topic
simply as a term.
A term can be a word or a phrase.
And in general, we can use these terms
to describe topics, so our first
thought is just to define a topic as
one term.
For example, we might have terms like
sports,
travel or science as you see here.
Now if we define a topic in this way,
we can analyze the coverage of such
topics in each document.
Here, for example, we might want to
discover to what extent document 1
covers sports and we found that 30% of
the content of document 1 is about sports.
And 12% is about the travel etc.
We might also discover Document 2 does
not cover sports at all, so the
coverage is zero, etc.
So now of course, as we discussed.
In the task definition for topic mining
and analysis, we have two tasks, one is to
discover the topics and the 2nd is to
analyze the coverage.
So let's first think about how we can
discover topics if we represent each
topic by a term.
So that means we need to mine K topical
terms from a collection.
Now there are of course many different
ways of doing that and.
We're going to talk about a natural way
of doing that, which is also likely
effective.
So first we're going to parse the text
data in the collection to obtain
candidate terms.
Here, candidate terms can be words or
phrases.
Let's say the simplest solution is to
just take each word as a term.
These words then become candidate
topics.
Then we're going to design a scoring
function to measure how good each term
is as a topic.
So how can we design such a function?
Well, there are many things that we can
consider.
For example, we can use pure statistics
to design such as scoring function.
Intuitively, we would like to favor
representative terms, meaning terms
that can represent a lot of content in
the collection.
So that would mean we want to favor a
frequent term.
However, if we simply use the frequency
to design the scoring function, then
the highest scored terms would be
general terms or functional terms, like "the", "a"
etc.
Those terms are very frequent
in English.
So we also want to avoid having such
words on the top, so we want to
penalize such words, but in general
would like the favor terms that are
fairly frequently but not so frequent.
So a particular approach could be
based on, TF-IDF weighting from
retrieval.
And TF stands for term frequency
IDF stands for inverse document
frequency and we talked about some of
these ideas in the lectures about the
discovery of word associations.
So these are statistical methods,
meaning that the function is defined
mostly based on statistics.
So the scoring function would be very
general.
It can be applied to any language and
any text.
But when we apply such an approach to a
particular problem, we might also be
able to leverage some domain specific
heuristics.
For example, in news we might favor
title words.
Actually, in general, we might want to
favor title words becauses the authors
tend to use the title to describe the
topic of an article.
If we're dealing with tweets, we could
also favor hashtags which are
invented to denote topics. So naturally
hashtags can be good candidates for
representing topics.
Anyway, after we have designed the
scoring function, then we can discover
the K topical terms by simply picking
K terms with the highest scores.
Now of course we might encounter a
situation where the highest scored
terms are all very similar.
They are semantically similar or
closely related or even synonyms.
So that's not desirable, so we
also want to have coverage over all the
content in the collection.
So we would like to remove redundancy
and one way to do that is to do a greedy
algorithm, which is sometimes called
maximal marginal relevance ranking.
Basically, the idea is to go down the
list based on our scoring function an
gradually take terms to collect the K
topical terms.
The first term of course will be picked
when we pick the next term.
We're going to look at the what terms
have already been picked and try to
avoid picking a term that's too similar.
similar.
So while we are considering the
ranking of term in the list,
we're also consider in the redundancy of
the candidate term with respect to the
terms that we already picked.
With some thresholding then we can
get balance of redundancy removal and
also high score over term.
OK so after this then we will get K
topical terms and those can be regarded
as the topics that we
discovered from the collection.
Next let's think about how we can
compute the topic coverage
pi sub
i j
So looking at this picture, we have
sports, travel and science and these topics
and now suppose you are given a
document
How should we figure out the coverage
of each topic in the document?
One approach can be to simply count
occurrences of these terms.
So for example, sports might have
occurred four times in this document,
and travel occurred twice, etc, and
then we can just normalize.
these counts as our estimate of the
coverage probability for each topic.
So in general the formula would be to
collect the counts of all the terms
that represented the topics and then
simply normalize them so that.
The coverage of each topic in the
document would add to one.
This forms a distribution over the
topics for the document to characterize
coverage of different topics in the
document.
Now, as always when we think about the
idea for solving problem, we have to
ask the question, how good is this one?
Or is this the best way of solving the
problem?
So now let's examine this approach.
In general, we have to do some
empirical evaluation by using actual
datasets and to see how well it works.
In this case, let's take a look at a
simple example.
Here we have the text document that is
about the NBA basketball game.
So in terms of the content, it's about
the sports.
But if we simply count these words that
represent our topics, and we will find
that the word sports actually did not
occur in the article, even though the
content is about the sports.
So the count of sports is zero.
That means the coverage of sports will
be
estimated
as zero.
Now of course.
The term science also did not occur in
the document, and it's estimated
also zero.
That's OK, but sports certainly is not
OK.
'cause we know the content is about
sports.
So this estimate has problem.
What's worse, term travel actually
occurred in the document, so when we
estimate the coverage of the topic
travel, we have gotten a non-zero count, so
it's estimated coverage would be non zero.
So this obviously is also not
desirable.
So this simple example illustrates some
problems of this approach. First,
when we count what words belong to the
topic, we also need to consider related
words.
We can't simply just count the topic.
word sports.
In this case, it did not occur at all,
but there are many related words like
basketball, game, etc.
So we need to count related words.
Also.
The second problem is that a word like
star can be actually ambiguous.
So here it probably means a basketball
star
But we can imagine it might also mean a
star on the Sky.
So in that case the star might actually
suggest perhaps a topic of science. So we need to deal with that as well. Finally, the main restriction of this approach is that we have only one term to describe this topic
So it cannot really describe complicated topics.
For example a very specialized topic would be hard to describe by
using just a word or one phrase, we
need to use more words, so this example
illustrates some general problems with
this approach of treating a term as
topic.
First, it lacks expressive power,
meaning that it can only represent the
symbol general topics.
But it cannot represent the complicated
topics that might require more words to
describe.
Second,
it's incomplete in vocabulary coverage,
meaning that the topic itself is only
represented as one term.
It does not suggest what other terms
are related to the topic, even if we're
talking about the sports, there are
many terms that are related, so it does
not allow us to easily count related
terms toward contributing to coverage
of this topic.
Finally, there's this problem of word
sense ambiguation, a topical term or
related term can be ambiguous.
For example, basketball star versus
star in the Sky.
So in the next lecture we're going to
talk about how to solve the problem
with probabilistic modeling of the topic.